as we sit here in 2021 i think
sustainability
continues to be one of the hottest
topics
in the retail industry and there's a
reason for that
you know america is basically grounding
garbage
we throw away three times as much stuff
today as we did 60 years ago
and if you look at textile trash in
particular
it's grown ninefold since 1916.
so more than ever we're buying cheap
clothing we're wearing it a few times
maybe and then we're throwing it away
and so i think that's part of the reason
you're starting to hear
more about something called re-commerce
so basically taking stuff that already
exists in the world
and repurposing it somehow reselling it
um
finding a way to get more life out of
new stuff
rather than you know rushing to buy
something that's brand new
[Music]
it's no different than certified
pre-owned lexus when you think about
quality items think about patagonia or
levi's or eileen fisher
these are items that you know people
enjoy but they've got a lot of life in
them
and oftentimes we change sizes we're
looking for something different
and for brands to be able to make it
easy
when you're done to hand those items
back and get the item you want
that's what we're all looking for grove
is a small startup out of san francisco
that runs resale programs for big brands
behind the scenes
one of their customers is levi's and as
of october
you can now go into a levi's store with
an old pair of jeans
maybe they haven't fit since college and
you can give them back
and get a gift card in return and then
what happens with that old pair of jeans
is that levi's will send it directly to
drove which has
a warehouse out in california and they
have 300
plus workers who are going to take a
look at that pair of jeans
they're going to note okay maybe there's
holes in the knees
any other peculiarities they're going to
clean it they're going to photograph it
and they're going to list it online for
sale
and so as a shopper you can now go to
levi's website
and there's a tab on there for used um
used products
and if you end up purchasing one it's
trill that's gonna put it in levi's
packaging and send it to your door
there have long been obviously thrift
stores and vintage shops
that buy and sell used clothing but i
would say in the last decade or so
we've seen a bunch of online
marketplaces
pop up that buy and sell used clothing
so think about a poshmark think about a
thread up
the real real or luxury items and all of
these
are our online marketplaces and it all
cuts out the brands though so this is
where trove is different
um trove is built as a white label
company so it's working with brands
directly
to help brands get into this space it's
estimated that
secondhand products represent a 28
billion dollar industry
and that's expected to more than double
to 64 billion by 2024.
[Music]
the move to recommerce is a massive
customer shift
and third-party marketplaces like the
threat ups and rear rails have
credentialized it when brands realize
they've got to be staying with customers
in this massive trend
for resale we make it easy we provide
the technology that allows brands to be
able to buy back these items
and make them sellable every item here
is unique
so every item has its own description
its own photograph
its its own individual identity and so
we make processing those
easy that's what we do trova is still
tiny but it's growing fast
it's raised 45 million dollars in
funding a lot of that coming from
investors who have an interest
in sustainability issues and last year
the number of items it processed
tripled to 600 000. there's some
skepticism
about how many brands will really get
into this and whether the brands that do
basically treating it as marketing stunt
rather than as
a real business opportunity like they
just want to cater
to young shoppers they want to stay
relevant and check that box
when it comes to sustainability and
certainly it's strange to see brands
that have long
like pushed this idea that you need new
new new
you need the latest style suddenly
saying actually why don't you come and
buy something that we made a year ago or
10 years ago
or maybe even longer and it's also
unclear
whether consumers are going to continue
buying used clothing at the same rate as
they are today
you know as we all know fashion is
notoriously fickle so what's in vogue
today
particularly a lot of style tomorrow you
know nobody knows you have to
acknowledge that there's a lot of waste
in the fashion industry so this is a way
to reuse
a lot of the products that are sitting
in our closets that are going unused
you